i do try to ignore it and just try to do
whatever's best for the kids
that's what i love about you because
take the high road yeah following a
whirlwind of public feuding on social
media between kanye west and kim
kardashian a source tells et the 44 year
old rapper has been laying low and is
focusing on healing
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
the 41 year old skims founder filed for
divorce from the grammy winner back in
february 2021 and while the two seem to
be on good terms for a while
co-parenting the four children they
share by 2022 things took a turn with
yay hurling a series of accusations at
kim on instagram you just gotta roll
with it and trashing her new boyfriend
pete davidson both online and in song
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
well now e.t source says kanye is trying
to disconnect from all the drama that
happened between them quote he is
focused on taking care of himself
getting healthier and removing himself
from all the craziness the source
explains that the musician cares deeply
about his family and kids and adds that
they are his number one priority so he's
working on himself
i just traveled to get something for ken
you went all the way to la to get
something for kim
you wear something else meanwhile yay
made his debut on the famous family's
new hulu series this week with a grand
gesture for kim
he got me all of the sex tape
oh my god and he flew home and got
and i met up with ray j at the airport
and got it all right oh kim sweet right
well on thursday ray j entered the chat
claiming on instagram that's not exactly
how it all went down the singer writes
all of this is a lie shaking my head
can't let them do this anymore so untrue
interesting well while we wait to hear
more about that kim's new man hit the
stage at the hollywood bowl for the
netflix is a joke comedy festival in la
on thursday night and weighed in on all
the kanye drama joking about the rapper
being a genius before telling the
audience being humiliated is weird when
you can't do anything about it it is
what it is but when it comes to kim a
source recently told et that the two are
in a great place in their relationship
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Music]
you